he is not only a Heisman Trophy winner
he's a Heisman Trophy winner and a
Superbowl Most Valuable Player is well
I'm sorry Brockman I know is against
your page it certainly did for the Green
Bay Packers and he has now made it hit
it big if you will as an analyst for
ESPN's College GameDay which means he's
gonna be part of the draft coverage for
ESPN Desmond Howard here on the program
how are you test I'm doing fantastic and
I'm gonna have to call on you to help me
will help me out with some of this draft
coverage stuff I mean I know that the
college players but I'm not sure about
all the needs of these in FL teams so
I'll have to lean on you for that you
know does I know how much I love you I
tell you that every time the amount of
excitement you gave me when you were
wearing the maize and blue is
immeasurable I have rooted for you every
step of the way but on that day draft
day you know I'm gonna be like Ray Lewis
coming out of the tunnel with the smoke
I mean we're kind of kind of competitors
that day I'm excited for for you for
that we'll get to that in a second but
okay all right let's uh let's get to the
business first
here the do you agree with the way that
the college football playoff rankings
were were were ordered one through let's
say eight Desmond yes I didn't have a
problem whatsoever I didn't think there
was an argument for anything outside of
the way that they ranked the teams I
know people talked about probably the
Buckeyes being ranked a little higher
than the Sooners I don't see how people
could rationally think that unless you
just unless you're just a person who who
subscribes to knee-jerk reactions and
you become a prisoner of the moment then
I get it but if you really look at the
body of work throughout a season then it
makes absolutely no sense whatsoever
it's even consider ranking Ohio State
over Oklahoma so walk me through the
nuts and bolts of that take does
well it's just what you see I mean first
and foremost I test I mean before that
game I mean you look at the Buckeyes and
if you look at the performance against
the Wolverines as being who they are
then they've underperformed pretty much
the whole year meaning they've won games
you know they came out on top in the
score when if when the final score was
posted but as far as what they looked
like in those games I mean they
struggled they sure the loss against
Maryland they struggled against Nebraska
they struggled against mr. Lewis they
struggled against Penn State that Penn
Station won that game I mean they had an
inexplicable call on four to five that
still baffles everyone who watched that
game and you just go down the line so in
my opinion if you're looking at the
performance on the field not just the
record then they underperformed their
talent level that they showed us that
Saturday or Saturday was just a game
they just played above their heads you
don't know today take the field again
and then how about the Purdue game I
mean come on
I mean you lose by four touchdowns to a
Purdue team so I mean you look at Texas
I mean look at Oklahoma and their only
loss was a shoot out by three points to
a ranked Texas team so I don't even see
what the comparisons are equal when you
look at the performances on the field
when Texas beat when Oklahoma beat a
team during the season after that game
they just beat them you know in the
scorers department they beat these teams
were you understood Oklahoma was the
best team on the field that day where no
house they beat Michigan State when they
beat Nebraska Maryland you didn't walk
away thinking okay the Buckeyes are the
best team on the field
the only time you in my opinion the only
time you really walked away thinking
that was last week when they played
Michigan so I don't see where it's even
comparable where you would try to
compare or how state especially their
body of work to Oklahoma's body of works
so far this season so then let's let's
let's go
hypothetical here starting from the top
Alabama blows out Georgia and everybody
else wins who do you put in Oklahoma
yeah I think I think you put in
Oklahoma's no I only big I don't even
think there's a discussion but you know
I'm sure other people would beg to
differ
it's Georgia so Georgia beats Alabama
shocks the world does Alabama with one
loss regardless of how it happened if it
was a two-touchdown if it was a reverse
result but the same tied game as the
national championship games is a one
loss Alabama team get in over an Ohio
State in Oklahoma Conference champion
rich if your thought process during the
season was Alabama's the top team in the
country they're the number one team in
the country right one game one loss
should not make you think okay they're
not even a top 14 like that's just
illogical so in my opinion if you're
supposed to put it in the best four
teams you know because we always argue
are we trying to put in the best four
teams or the most deserving four teams
so if the argument is for the best four
teams and for 12 or however many weeks
Alabama has been in your mind the best
team that they can't fall out of the top
four just from one loss so in my opinion
they're still even if they lose they're
still one of the best four teams in
college football so you still have in my
opinion you still put them in so Buckeye
fans Desmond Howard should wake up noon
Eastern on ABC and say hook em horns
hook em hook em right into CBS with
Nesler who's gonna be on the show on
Friday and say roll tide roll tide okay
right and that's the way they get in as
the fourth seed should they beat
northwestern correct oh yeah yeah I
think I think I think but the committee
will have to make that it would be a
tough decision but they will have like
you said they would have to roll North
West and I was talking to a friend of
mine like pretty much the media is
telling Ohio
State and telling Oklahoma you don't
have to win these games you have to go
out and blow out your opponent in these
games Saturday you have to go out and
manhandle Texas I'm talking about you
need to not just go out there and try to
get a victory you need to go out there
man hell and turn Ohio State the same
thing just a victory hey maybe a three
or six-point victory over northwestern
ain't gonna cut it
urban you got to go out there and beat
them by three touchdowns by four
touchdowns in a very impressive and
oppressive very impressive fashion so
that's what the media is telling these
guys and then Oklahoma have a they have
an advantage rich because obviously they
play the eight o'clock game so at that
point you know they'll know what took
place between Oklahoma and Texas and now
they know what they have to go out there
and do against Northwestern so it's
really interesting how this thing is
unfolding yeah but so so but if roll
tide happens and and Oklahoma gets
hooked again how does Ohio State not
make it four regardless of the final
score over Northwestern then who would
make it instead of them under that
scenario the wins
Alabama wins right two losses right and
then Oklahoma loses doesn't doesn't
doesn't Ohio State just need to bend win
by one single point in order to get in
to me gonna be the toughest UCF good
work cuz UCF could sneak in is an
undefeated team despite not having their
starting quarterback and you know you
just hit on a very important point
without without Milton McKenzie is going
to be tough for them to put UCF in there
because that's going to be a determining
factor now we need to see how UCF looks
against Memphis to know I got to go out
and play convincingly against Memphis
because that was a shootout that they
were in trouble and for you know three
and a half quarters against Memphis and
that's when they did have their starting
quarterback so it is not that you see us
it's just gonna walk in there and roll
over Memphis
come Saturday either so that's another
one to keep an eye on - all right so I'm
building up to this moment here Desmond
I've been building up this entire time
okay Alabama wins roll tide roll tide
tide rolls Oklahoma the horns hook'em
they're out again Texas gets him
duuude are you telling me doesn't take
much for me to root against Ohio State
and the fact that I did go to
Northwestern got my graduate degree from
there so I do have a rooting interest in
that regard
they're telling me northwestern beats
the Ohio State all those three things
happen Michigan at seven that's a clear
path to the number four basket correct
Desmond am I wrong it looks that way I
mean and that's what a lot of people you
know who real yeah I mean that's that's
how it's potentially looking and I've
heard that scenario tossed out several
times and I mean I think it's a
obviously percentage-wise a very small
percentage of like Dumb and Dumber
you're saying we've got a chance
[Laughter]
the Wolverines despite giving up a 60
burger in the game that they were
supposed to win it was does should have
had to win needed to win should win they
have if all of those results happen
sitting on their couch the ability to
not even win the Big Ten championship
game and be the fourth seed Desmond is
that really what this college football
playoff committee is telling Wolverine
fans and the rest of the world they need
a lot of help but we've seen a similar
scenario before I believe with Ohio
State and Penn State where Penn State
beat Ohio State head to head Penn State
won the Big Ten championship but some
odd way or how if they ended up getting
in that year even though they sat at
home and watch the Big Ten championship
that that Saturday afternoon so we've
seen a similar scenario take place
before that would be nuts Desmond and
our bananas man so I do want to ask you
this question the few minutes I have
left with you Desmond on behalf of all
the Wolverines who look to people like
you and
Charles Brady the goats touch what
what's happening what gives what what
happened on Saturday and what is
happening in in this rivalry where
Michigan can't buy it right now
Desmond Wow you know that last idea was
a shock to everybody I think even the
Wolverines I think Don Brown is was
shocked and my kid just put everything
in one basket like we can't beat them I
mean two years ago you know three inches
away from beating Ohio State and a lot
of people said that we got screwed on
that fourth down call with JT Barrett
that Michigan should have won that game
by Michigan did win that game but we got
screwed on the call so but this was a
little different because of the defense
things you just never expected the
defense to go out there and Ohio State's
office to put with like 55 points so on
the deep snow and but it's also a black
punt for a touchdown so I know he scored
62 but what was the black bus was that
was a special thing not just that though
Desmond it's like some kid didn't know
that's never caught a pass before some
freshman suddenly dominating and so
that's why I'm wondering like where's
our freshman like Haskins came off the
bench last year and won the game like
that you know I mean these are the
questions that are being asked right
it's very difficult questions and I
understand I'm I'm asking it to you I
don't know if you have an answer but
what is there an answer as to what
there's a the problem is well I mean I
think from a recruiting standpoint it
seems like they have some players out
there who are ready to participate and
play immediately and be impactful I
don't think that they're asking these
guys do anything special they're not
asking these guys to go out there and
win games but it's like can you run a
crossing route you know can you run a up
and up and out and up or you know really
simple Rob's birthdate what happened is
riah day the offensive coordinator he
got the matchups that he was looking for
on our man-to-man coverage and guys just
go out there playing pitching catch and
running the Reno running around and
making some plays at the end of the day
so in my opinion I think they were
on film I mean on the field they look
faster these guys were fast guys they
had especially in there on the perimeter
and they did that simple things that
coach day asked of them
but to me from a recruiting standpoint
you're gonna have to recruit some speed
so you can contend with some of these
guys if you're gonna play that sort of
man-to-man
but they did a great job schematically
of going after certain players and doing
certain things on office that kept our
deepest on his heels well I guess that
this whole conversation will look mood
anyway when when Alabama and Texas and
northwestern all win and Michigan gets
in and beats Nick Saban and then they
they take revenge on Notre Dame or maybe
be Clemson and win it all anyway
Desmond's right there you go exactly
that's the one that we're hoping for
it's one more thing is um but is this
cool Ohio State is no like that's me
that's the big question
right because we haven't seen that sort
of performance the whole year that's
death so I'm still trying to figure out
is this really who they are or did some
guys just play over their heads one
afternoon when their backs were against
the wall they're a home underdog and
they're playing against their rival like
just some guys just rise to the cage and
play over their head because the fact of
the matter is where was this against
Purdue where was this against Michigan
State how about Marilyn how about
Nebraska like you've never really seen
these guys so I can't have a knee-jerk
reaction rich and say man these guys are
just completely outstanding I need to
see it consistently before I can say
yeah these guys just blow your way with
you know their talent you know because
if you got this type of talent then why
do you lose by almost 30 points to
Purdue why do you struggle against the
Nebraska team while you struggle up in
East Lansing's against Michigan State
and then the list goes on and on and on
so it's hard for me to just say these
guys are exceptional across the board
and the skilled positions I knew that
Haskins was one of the best if not the
best quarterback and
big team when it comes to just throwing
the ball there's no doubt about that but
all these other guys they haven't shown
up on Saturdays but seem like they all
showed up on the same day at the same
time it had an outstanding performance
and they did last one for your dad's
does too again your Heisman vote right
now I like - what - let the championship
game play play play out off and just
watch everyone because I think the
calimary is an exceptional talent I
thoroughly enjoy watching this young man
play I think he's a better passer than
people give him credit for I mean when
you have a guy like that rich that's so
electric is so dynamic out in space
people get wound by that because he just
leave guys just standing still looking
ridiculous and I think they don't really
pay a lot of attention so how he throws
the ball but I think he's a really
underrated pass or - well I mean I don't
know if theirs is still a trophy left
because I think Baker Mayfield just
handed the Heisman a huge axe in this
past week if you saw that Desmond I
think that's already done Baker gave it
out gave my husband I was born and
raised in Cleveland so I pay attention
to the brown so yeah I did see that oh
yeah oh yeah it does really love to chat
and I'm there for you for the draft you
know that know you I appreciate you more
thanks for calling in Desmond that's
that's Desmond Howard check out College
GameDay he's heading there right now
it's going to Atlanta is there gonna be
there for the SEC championship came the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience